Na doch, passt doch.
Moin, Mo Overflow.
Ah ja Leute, ich weiß es ist schon spät, wir werden heute auch nicht all zu viel machen.
Ich hab mir gedacht, ich komm aber trotzdem mal an.
Euren Icarus.
Steht nicht viel an.
Vielleicht gucken wir ein paar Sachen uns an.
Und wenn es irgendwelche spannenden Sachen gibt, schreibt es in den Chat.
Kann man drüber schwätzen.
Aber ansonsten kriege ich halt nicht mehr viel auf die Reihe.
Ich bin ziemlich kaputt.
Fakenet auch am Start, nice.
Bist du auch auf der? Moment, ich erkenne es nicht.
Was?
Ist das eine JavaScript Konferenz oder klingt irgendwie so?
IPC sagt mir nichts.
Klingt, klingt aber nach Frontend JavaScript Kram.
Gibt es von den Commander Kriegermetalscheiben noch welche?
Ja, gibt es.
Und zwar, kann ich euch mal den Gelegenheit zeigen.
Ich hab letztens eBay Kleinanzeigen was gefunden, fand ich witzig.
Irgendjemand hat letztens bei eBay Kleinanzeigen eine von den Max FPS Scheiben verkauft.
Und es ging auch weg.
Das ging auch weg, fand ich witzig.
Warte mal, eBay Kleinanzeigen durchsuchen.
Warte mal, guck mal.
Max FPS.
Ah ne, ist nicht mehr drinne.
Irgendjemand hat letztens so einen von diesen Scheiben gekauft, verkauft, auf eBay Kleinanzeigen.
Zufällig gesehen.
Also ich hab noch eine.
Ansonsten, ich habe keinen Plassen Schimmer mehr.
Was aus dem Rest geworden ist.
Also den Rest hab ich ja verschickt.
Ich hab noch eine.
Ja.
Die Stonks.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab nicht mehr reingeguckt in den letzten paar Tagen.
Eher nicht gut, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Das ist aber nicht der Richtige.
Oh, ist wieder hochgegangen.
Sind die Stonks wieder.
Okay, die Stonks sind wieder ein bisschen gestiegen.
Aber egal.
Ja, ich weiß nicht mehr wieviel es weggegangen ist.
Ich glaub 50 Euro oder so.
Ich hab, wie gesagt, ich hab letztens bei eBay Kleinanzeigen gesehen.
Ja gut, wer will.
Wer will.
Eine Max-FPS-Scheibe von 2011.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das so der Wahnsinns.
Na ja.
Es ist eine Rarität.
Das ist richtig.
So viele gibt es davon nicht.
Schon Fortschritte bei der Jobsuche.
Ja, da kann ich euch was zu erzählen.
Wir müssten eigentlich im Stream mal keine Bewerbung.
Ein Lebenslauf und eine Skill-Liste erstellen.
Wobei, den Lebenslauf, den kann ich jetzt nicht komplett erstellen im Stream.
So mit Name und allem und Anschrift und Geduld.
Wobei, nein, muss ja nicht in den Lebenslauf.
Aber ihr wisst vielleicht mein Foto und so.
Das geht nicht.
Aber ich müsste eigentlich mal eine ordentliche Skill-Liste machen.
Und ich bin mega faul, das wisst ihr.
Wir haben doch schon, wir haben eine Programmier-Skill-Liste erstellt.
Ich glaube, mit der anderen sind wir nie wirklich weit gekommen.
Da habe ich drei Punkte draufgeschrieben und fertig.
Keine Ahnung, wo die hin ist.
Kann ich mich auch gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Leute, wisst ihr, eigentlich sollte heute um 15.30 Uhr...
Jetzt darf der nicht erfahren.
Derjenige, der mich da angeschrieben hat, der kennt mich ja.
Ich mache die Sachen, die ich mache, aber gründlich, dass ich damit mich nie wieder
auseinandersetzen muss.
Das ist der Trick dabei.
Also eigentlich sollte um 15.30 Uhr heute ein Video kommen.
Und wisst ihr warum das Video nicht gekommen ist?
Das Video hat eine Sponsoring drin.
Und die Leute, die das sponsoren, die haben es nicht geschafft, mir einen Tracking-Link
zu schicken, obwohl sie das schon irgendwie seit, frag mich nicht, fünf Tagen machen
wollen.
Ich hoffe, die kriegen das hin bis morgen, weil morgen geht das Video an.
Geht tatsächlich mal wieder um Battlefield.
Und mit oder ohne Sponsoring ist mir egal.
Zur Not schneide ich das Sponsoring raus und lade es noch mal hoch.
Nee, nee, nicht BF3, was, zu Battlefield 2042 gibt es mehr Kisten jetzt.
Nein, nein, nicht DICE Sponsor.
Also ich sage euch nicht, wer der Sponsor ist, aber ich kann euch sagen, es ist ein
Pay to Win-Mobile-Game.
Nichts, was ich normalerweise spielen würde, aber Sponsoring-Money.
Und ich bin bestimmt wieder genauso überzeugend wie bei Genshin Impact in meinem Sponsoring.
Bestimmt jeder überzeugend wird es danach spielen, so wie ich das, wie leidenschaftlich
ich das vorgetragen habe wieder.
Nein, das ist nicht Raid Shadow Legends.
Es ist irgendwie so ein Peggle-Klon.
Ich muss es mir glücklicherweise nur kurz angucken.
Einer dieser vielen so Peggle-Juwelen-Games, würde ich sie normalerweise im Leben nicht
spielen.
Tja, da weiß ich aktuell nicht so genau, was ich machen soll für YouTube.
Es gibt ein Thema, also Just for Fun würde ich das gerne mal zeigen.
Microsoft hat ja für Windows jetzt ein eigenes Cleaning-Tool, was ich schon irgendwie lächerlich
finde, das wollte ich mir mal angucken.
Aber sonst fällt mir da ehrlich gesagt gerade nichts ein.
Es gibt keine großen Hacks, es gibt keine großen Sicherheitslücken, also die für die
Allgemeinheit da bei mir so relevant wären.
Ansonsten weiß ich gar nicht, was ich machen soll in der Richtung auf YouTube.
Ich könnte mich tatsächlich mal auslassen.
Sag mal, ist die Musik zu laut?
Nee, oder?
Musste eigentlich passen.
Kommt mir zu laut vor.
Irgendwie kommt die mir zu laut vor.
Kann auch sein, weil ich ein bisschen kaputt bin.
Die Skillliste war doch fertig.
Ach, die.
Wirklich?
Ernsthaft, ich hab schon mal eine Skillliste erstellt.
Wo ist die?
Hier, da.
Pass mal auf.
Fuck.
Skills.
Flutter Dart?
Was zum Teufel?
Ich hab keine Ahnung von Flutter und Dart.
Warum hab ich das reingeschrieben?
What the fuck?
Nee, die war nicht fertig.
Da fehlt doch eigentlich so gut wie alles Relevante.
Ha, Cluster Kram.
Ja, das kann ich.
Und das schreibe ich natürlich so rein.
Alles klar.
WebAssembly.
C++.
Ah, hier hab ich sinnvolle Sachen reingeschrieben.
Okay, das muss ich mir tatsächlich mal raussuchen.
Wo hatten wir das?
Das sieht nach der alten.
Ist das die neue oder die alte VM?
Das müsste schon die neue sein.
Also die mittelneue.
Hast du schon was mit Laravel gemacht?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Nicht gelogen hab ich tatsächlich.
Da macht ihr Auge was?
Ja, ich hab was mit Laravel gemacht schon.
Ich hab damals für meinen Battlefield 4 Server, zum Beispiel in Laravel, eine Statistik-Site
für jeden Spieler erstellt.
Also auto-generated Statistik-Site für jeden Spieler erstellt.
Aus der Datenbank.
Battlefield hat Kills und Statistiken und KD und sowas.
Beziehungsweise muss man sich selbst ausrechnen.
Hat ein bisschen Statistik in der Datenbank geschrieben.
Dann hab ich das automatisch dann gerendert, wenn das einer an die Seite aufgemacht hat.
So, Skills.
Skills.
Tatsächlich, Leute.
What the fuck?
Ich hab tatsächlich schon mal angefangen, eine Skill-Liste zu machen.
Eine Skill-Liste zu machen.
Natürlich so halb gemint im Stream, aber...
Wahnsinn.
Wusste ich gar nicht mehr.
Tatsächlich?
Guck dir mal da.
Oh, Suze.
Minus, Minus, Minus.
Ich hasse Suze, Alter.
Geh mal weg.
Da fehlt aber die Hälfte.
Da fehlt die Hälfte.
Aber das ist eine ganz gute Grundlage.
Das ist tatsächlich eine ganz gute Grundlage.
Windows ist Kack W.
Ey, das lass ich so drinne in den Soft-Skills.
Exakt so schick ich das dann dahin.
Soft-Skills, Kack W.
Äh, nicht Soft-Skills.
Was hab ich denn?
Soft-Skills stand da unten.
Windows, das schick ich exakt so hin.
Windows, Kack W.
So, Netlify.
Netlify++, Alter.
Netlify hab ich einmal den statischen Sachen drauf kopiert.
Und das war's.
Cloudflare hab ich tatsächlich schon ein bisschen was mitgemacht.
AWS hab ich ein bisschen was, aber nicht viel.
Gtcp hab ich auch ein bisschen was.
Elstar Cloud kenn ich mich gut aus.
Elstar kenn ich mich ganz gut aus.
Digital Ausgabe.
Alibaba.
Das war doch gemimt, oder?
Ich hab noch nicht einmal einen Account gehabt für die beiden Alibaba Cloud, Alter.
Cobol.
Aber wichtig, wichtig, dass Cobol drinne ist.
Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Was war das?
Ups.
Framework Flutter Dart, Alter, da wird ein Schwachsinn reingeschrieben.
Lul.
Jammel, Jason, alles klar.
Ha, ha, klasse.
Da fehlt doch, da fehlt doch mehr oder weniger alles Wichtige.
Ich kann immer im Lebenslauf Links zu Videos schicken.
Ey, Quatsch.
Ich hasse, ja, das kann ich da nicht so reinschreiben, aber das ist so, ja.
Scrum, ITIL, Kanban, AGI, Lean, Fivehead, T-Shaped Teams, Test Driven Development, Clique, alles,
alles dabei, alles dabei.
Aber ohne Scheiß, das muss ich mir merken, dass ich hier so eine Liste schon mal erstellt
hab.
Die ist zwar zur Hälfte gemimt im Stream, aber da ist auch was Sinnvolles dabei.
Shithub.
Packt man heutzutage seinen Shithub Link in den Lebenslauf rein?
Hier.
Soll ich meinen Shithub Link in den Lebenslauf packen?
Wo ist die vertikale Agilität?
Wie gesagt, bei uns ist das alles schon diagonal.
Oh, man sieht, dass ich hier tatsächlich angefangen habe mal ernsthaft an einem Projekt
zu arbeiten.
Sonst vorher blub, blub, blub, blub, blub und jetzt blub, blub, blub, blub.
Warum nicht?
Joa.
Weil da teilweise ziemlich cringe Sachen drin sind an Code.
Mit dem Repo Namen, ja.
Eben hatte ich gerade ne coole Idee, wollte ich sagen.
Chat, muss ich bloß was erzählen, aber jetzt hab ich's wieder vergessen.
Boomer Brain.
Aufräumen.
Wie findet ihr das nicht?
Findet ihr das nicht gut, dass da steht Keque Test nur gepusht, weil mich der Chat sonst
geflamt hätte?
Aja, ja.
Aber ich finde, so muss das eigentlich auch sehen.
Prisilul.
Das war doch das BDO Screen Capture Tool, oder?
Ja, aber hier hab ich tatsächlich mal ernsthaft angefangen, was zu machen.
Na gut.
Das Chinesische, was du gezeigt hast, ok, ich weiß nicht mal, um was es ging, aber was
ich da gerade erzählt hab im Stream.
Ne, noch nicht.
Also ich werd das folgendermaßen machen.
Ich hab am Montag mit jemandem telefoniert, den ich noch kannte von früher auf der Arbeit
und die haben gesagt, der hat gesagt, Max, ich hab da ein Video gesehen.
Kein Witz jetzt.
Max, ich hab da ein Video, das ist wirklich kein Scheiß.
Max, ich hab da ein Video gesehen, wir haben einen Job für dich.
So ungefähr lief das.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, ah ja, nice, erzähl mal ein bisschen.
Hat er erzählt, ich find das klingt wirklich nicht übel.
Und ich hab mich jetzt mit ihm drauf geeinigt.
Das hat dann hab ich zum ersten Mal, ich hab da nie Wert drauf gelegt.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Dann hab ich zum ersten Mal Senior in meinem Jobtitel drinne stehen.
Und ich mein, das passt ja zu mir auch.
Ich bin ja schon fast Senior.
Mit 38 ist man Boomer genug, um Senior zu sein.
Ich wollt schon immer mal Senior DevOps Engineer oder sowas bei mir im Jobtitel stehen haben.
Ne, ist mir eigentlich total egal.
Aber letztendlich hab ich dann auch Senior drinne stehen.
Zumindest hab ich mit ihm telefoniert.
Und wir haben ein bisschen Zeug erzählt.
Und der hat mir das natürlich dann versucht, schmackhaft zu machen.
Dass das ein ganz toller Arbeitgeber ist.
Und wir haben uns jetzt drauf geeinigt.
Ich mach mal einen Lebenslauf und eine Skillliste und schick ihm das.
Also er hat auch schon das Okay von seinem Chef und alles.
Also ich denke mal, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht ganz so blöd anstelle,
da stehen dann die Chancen wirklich ganz gut.
Ja, und mal gucken, was dann unterm Strich rauskommt.
So von garantiertem Homeoffice und Geld und Teilzeit.
Nur müssen wir mal gucken, ob das passt, was da unterm Strich rauskommt.
Und wenn das passt, dann bin ich wahrscheinlich zum 31.12. in Frankfurt weg.
Also nicht in Frankfurt.
Nicht zwar häufig in Frankfurt weg, aber dort, wo ich jetzt arbeite, weg.
Oder aber, die sagen zu mir, Max, wir wollen nicht, dass du gehst.
Wir geben dir jetzt alles, was du willst und mehr Geld.
Wäre auch eine Möglichkeit, ich glaub's ja nicht.
Weil bis das da wieder durch alle 175 Hierarchieebenen durch ist, bin ich weg.
Also was, genau das gleiche Umfeld wie jetzt.
Ähnlich.
Also tatsächlich, ich denke mal, es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so viel Unterschied
rein von der Technologie und dem, was man macht.
Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem grundsätzlich anderer Laden.
Das heißt, da werden die Dinge auch anders gehandelt.
Da muss man sich dann halt dran gewöhnen.
Moin, BlueSky.
Ja.
Aber wie gesagt, ich hab auch schon was mit Laravel gemacht.
Ich hab für meinen Battlefield-Server eine Statistikseite erstellt.
Sachen aus der Datenbank abgefragt und so Zeug.
Das ist ein PAP-Framework, ja.
Der Desktop, wieso?
Der Desktop ist POG.
Guck mal da, da ist sogar aji.waff.
Was ist denn das?
Ah, verstehe.
Das ist das also.
Warum genau hab ich das auf dem Desktop?
Was ist der Grund dafür, diese Waffe auf dem Desktop zu haben?
Na, man weiß es nicht.
Schnell Zugriff.
Aber ich brauch keinen Schnellzugriff.
Schnellzugriff hab ich doch hier schon.
Hab ich doch alles da.
Dann ist der langsam Zugriff.
Oh je, mein Beileid.
Suze ist eklig, ich mag Suze nicht.
Nur 5-Hat.
Meinst du, du bist mehr als 5-Hat?
Wie viel Hat bist du denn?
Dann sollte ich besser mein GitHub nicht mitschicken.
Meine Dokumentation und Kommentare sind legendär.
Vor allem die vielen Tests, die ich habe.
Also jedes meiner Projektrepos hat mindestens 90% Testabdeckung auf GitHub.
Mindestens.
Wenn nicht mehr.
Und Code Pattern sind auch richtig gute Sachen dabei.
Pass mal auf, das beste Pattern ist immer noch...
Ich glaube in Friesi Lul ist das beste Pattern.
Das war eigentlich nur zum Spaß drin.
Macht keinen Sinn, aber wenn das einer sieht, der lässt mich nie was programmieren.
Ups, nee nicht das.
Ich glaube in Friesi Lul war das drin.
Moment.
Was ist das?
Warum hat es einen Testordner?
Das geht aber nicht.
Okay, ich habe ernsthaft keine Ahnung, was das hier eigentlich mehr gewesen ist.
Screenshot?
Haben wir Screenshots gemacht?
Dieses DirectX, was habe ich denn da gemacht?
Habe ich da ausgesucht zwei Projekte?
Zwei Projekte in einem irgendwie?
Texterkennung?
Ach hier doch, das ist das.
Guck mal, bestes.
Bestes, bestes Pattern.
Also ich glaube damit stellt mich jeder ein.
Die Fang Bewerbung ist raus.
Es macht vor allem gar keinen Sinn.
Ich caste das gleiche Int mehrfach.
Das habe ich damals einfach nur sinnlos copy pasted im Stream.
Aber wenn das jemand sieht.
Apoc erstmals, guck mal, Public Api Key, easy.
Okay Leute, ich habe keinen Plan mehr, was ich da gemacht habe.
Aber Kats FPS.
Senior Max FPS.
2001 schreibe ich da nicht rein.
Ich fange mit meinem Lebenslauf an, weil ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Wen juckt die Schule?
Oder wo fängt man da heutzutage an in so einem Lebenslauf?
Also ich mache das Ganze seit 2007 jetzt.
15 Jahre.
Da schreibt man auch keine Schule mehr rein oder sowas oder?
Real Friteo, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Subscriptions.
Ich schreibe da auch seit der Ausbildung rein, das reicht.
Was soll ich da hier sonst noch aus der Antike schreiben?
Ich schreibe die Ausbildung rein, schreibe ich Ausbildung.
Dann bis dann Internet Provider, schreibe ich den Namen dahinter.
Das sage ich euch jetzt nicht.
Danach System oder Server Administration, da und da.
Dann Frankfurt Bank, da und da, ab da.
DevOps Engineer, blablabla.
Ja, muss ich mir mal ausdenken.
Ich bin aber faul, was sowas angeht zum Erstellen.
Der Alchemist, moin.
Nehm einen Generator.
Der Generator schreibt da aber nichts freien von mir.
Oder du meinst so einen Generator, wo man ihn füttern kann mit ein paar Sachen.
Ach, das kriege ich schon hin.
Ich war mir mehr Gedanken über die Skillliste.
Da vergesse ich die Hälfte.
Und die wird lang.
Die wird wirklich lang.
Guck mal allein schon, was wir hier im Stream alles gemacht haben.
Da muss ich auch C++ WebAssembly reinschreiben.
Weiß ich ja nicht, ob ich das brauche oder nicht.
Ah, ausnahmsweise ist gestartet.
Hast du Urlaub?
Ne, aber soll ich mal was sagen, Leute?
Apropos Urlaub.
Ich habe heute mal in meine Zeiterfassung geguckt.
Und ich habe festgestellt, ihr kennt mich ja, ich habe den ganzen Dezember schon mal eingetragen,
Urlaub ist auch schon genehmigt.
Ich habe jetzt aber noch vier Tage Urlaub übrig.
Das heißt, ich kann noch fast zwei Wochen vorher Urlaub nehmen.
Das heißt wiederum, dass ich quasi nur noch drei Wochen dieses Jahr arbeiten muss.
Bis zum eine Woche.
Normalerweise hätte ich ab da Urlaub.
Das kann ich noch dabei nehmen.
Und das kann ich noch dabei nehmen.
Also ab.
Ich habe Urlaub.
Ab hier.
Ab 18 ist der letzte Arbeitstag.
Also noch drei Wochen.
Naja, dreieinhalb Wochen, wenn die Woche rum ist.
Aber drei Wochen, drei Wochen.
Und dann ist für dieses Jahr Schluss.
Zeit für Bewerbungsgespräche.
Ach, ich mache jetzt diese eine Sache da und mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Und dann schauen wir mal, was ich, was ich da alles so ergibt.
Ich mache im Dezember wahrscheinlich keinen riesen Bewerbungsstells mit Bewerbungsschreiben
oder so.
Schauen wir mal.
Was ich höchstens mache, ist vielleicht die Kündigung abschicken.
Macht die IT für die öffentliche Verwaltung beste.
Moment.
Meinst du, du machst das?
Oder ich soll mir sowas suchen in der Verwaltung.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Was ist in dem Testordner eigentlich drin?
Moment, das interessiert mich jetzt.
Ich muss mal kurz reingucken.
Moment, nicht der 4er Champ.
Prisilul.
Prisilul-Test.
Test.
Test-Screenshot.
Das hat sogar Kommentare.
Das ist doch nicht von mir.
Das habe doch nicht ich gemacht.
Diese Tests im Leben nicht.
Ich kenne mich.
Ich schreibe schon mal garantiert keine Kommentare oben drüber.
Moment.
Git-History.
Wer hat das gemacht?
Aha.
Der Ruben Maurer war das.
Pull-Request.
Verstehe.
Ich habe mich schon gewundert.
Von mir ist das nicht.
MVP hier.
Ja, wir haben OCR gemacht über irgendeine OCR-API.
Friteo, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich glaube, ich habe schon gesehen, aber macht ja nichts.
Da bin ich gerade schon dabei.
Also Video, was morgen kommt, hat Pay2Win Mobile Game als Sponsoring.
Ich meine, schlimmer geht es ja kaum noch.
Es ist nicht Raid Shadow Legends.
Danach kommt noch ein Video für Gaming Equipment, nenne ich es mal.
Und dann mal gucken.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was mir aufgefallen ist?
Das Bahn Flames.
Das Bahn Flames richtig viele Likes bekommen auf Twitter.
Okay, Max FPS.
Wie heißen die?
DB, okay, Twitter, Bahn, Personenverkehr.
Genau.
So, und ich habe einfach random gestern mal wieder bekräftigt.
Sag mal, was haben die?
Haben die jetzt irgendwie neue Social Media Team oder hier?
So, ich habe einfach mal wieder bekräftigt vor ein paar Tagen, dass ich.
Wo ist mein?
Haben die mich ausgeplendet?
Kann man Sachen ausplenden lassen auf Twitter?
Geht das?
Wenn es dir nicht gefällt.
Ich habe Angst, hier durchzuscrollen.
Warum sind hier irgendwelche Grills drinnen auf einmal?
Was hat das mit der Bahn zu tun?
Was?
Ich will den Bahn Post sehen, nicht irgendwelche.
Die Bahn hat mich ausgeplendet.
Schau mal, ich bin da nicht mehr dabei.
Guck mal.
Doch, ja, da bin ich.
Guck mal, 438.
Ich habe einfach nur geschrieben, ich hasse euch.
438 Likes, easy.
Das kriege ich normalerweise nicht mal auf Main Tweets so viele.
Aber anscheinend können sich viele damit identifizieren.
Bin ich da einzeln noch nie im Urlaub?
Wenn ich sage, ich habe Urlaub, heißt nichts, zwangsläufig,
dass ich in Urlaub fliege, sondern dass ich erst mal nicht arbeiten gehe.
Und dass du mal Urlaub eingereicht hast auf der Arbeit, gehe ich mal schon von aus.
Weil du musst ja, du hast ja gesetzliche Urlaubstage.
Du kommst ja gar nicht drum herum.
In Urlaub geflogen bin ich jetzt auch schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr.
Ich überlege gerade mal, was war das Letzte, wo ich mit dem Flugzeug in Urlaub bin?
Das war entweder in die Türkei und das ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Da war noch nicht Erdogan und sonst was angesagt.
Ich glaube, ich habe eine Mücke da oben an der Decke.
Warte mal kurz.
Stellt, da komme ich jetzt nicht dran.
Entweder war es in Lanzarote oder es war in der Türkei.
Aber Türkei ist schon zu lange her, das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Es ist auf jeden Fall schon eine ganze Weile her, wo ich zuletzt mal in Urlaub geflogen bin.
Wie hoch ist dein Mindestgehalt, was du haben möchtest?
Soll ich das jetzt sagen?
Ich habe prinzipiell keine Schmerzen, mit das im Stream zu sagen.
Ich habe ja ein Video aufgenommen, wie viel ich aktuell verdiene.
Wobei das schon ein bisschen her ist.
Aber ich weiß nicht, weil wenn ich jetzt sage, was das Mindeste ist, wofür ich anfangen würde
und das kriegt, das hört einer, dann weiß er, wenn ich mehr sage, dass er es mir nicht geben muss.
Keine Ahnung, ob das taktisch so geschickt ist.
Mal schauen, was da raus kommt.
Die Bahn sucht garantiert, aber zur Bahn gehe ich nicht.
Kannst ja deine Meinung ändern, hast du recht.
Also ich würde sagen, so für um die 80K mache ich es.
Das ist dann ungefähr das, was ich jetzt bei mir auf der Arbeit verdiene, ein Ticken mehr als das,
was ich jetzt bei mir auf der Arbeit verdiene.
Und wichtig ist mir vor allem halt Homeoffice.
Und dementsprechend auch irgendwas Schriftliches, was Homeoffice angeht.
Weil wenn ich eins gelernt habe, dort wo ich aktuell arbeite,
dass irgendwelche mündlichen oder irgendwelche, wie sagt man so, Bekenntnisse, was man denn machen will,
dass Papier nicht wert sind, worauf sie geschrieben sind.
Oder die Mail nicht wert sind, in der sie geschrieben werden.
Also das muss schriftlich sein und unterschrieben.
Homeoffice oder Fernarbeit?
Ja, läuft aufs gleiche raus, oder?
Gut, ich meine, du hast recht, streng genommen.
Es sind zwar unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe, aber meistens läuft es doch aufs gleiche raus.
Nee, da soll Remote drinstehen.
Da soll Remote drinstehen.
Das muss nicht Homeoffice sein.
Ich will einfach nur, dass ich von woanders arbeiten kann.
Hat auch den Vorteil, die müssen wir keinen Arbeitsplatz zur Verfügung stellen.
Vielleicht einen Laptop oder so.
Würdest du kündigen, ohne was Neues zu haben?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Ich weiß es noch nicht genau.
Kommt drauf an, wie sehr die mir auf den Keks gehen.
Beziehungsweise wie sehr sich was an meinen Schmerzpunkten ändert.
Wenn sich da was ändert, nicht.
Wenn sich nichts ändert, was das Thema Homeoffice angeht.
Auch was Perspektiven und Bezahlung angeht.
Ich meine, man muss ja zumindest mal ein bisschen was in Aussicht haben.
Sonst soll es die Motivation herkommen.
Tja, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch kündigen, ohne was Neues zu haben.
Ich meine, ganz im Ernst, ich habe einen riesen Vorteil.
Beziehungsweise einen Pluspunkt, den viele nicht haben.
Und zwar, als erstes, ich schaue mal die Branche, in der ich arbeite.
IT-technisch vor allem, wenn du ein bisschen Ahnung hast.
Was ich mir jetzt einfach mal selbst zutraue, dass ich ein bisschen Ahnung habe.
Da findest du aktuell easy was.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ein Stream gemacht, hatte drei Anfragen danach.
Ich habe mit einer ganzen Ecke mehr Geld.
Ich habe ein Video gemacht.
Auf einmal melden sich irgendwelche Ex-Kollegen und Leute.
Hier, Max, wir haben einen Job für dich.
Also es ist wirklich an jeder Ecke gerade was zu finden.
Und das zweite ist, es gibt eigentlich sogar noch mehr Punkte.
Warum ich mir da wenig Gedanken mache.
Das nächste ist, ich habe ein Haus.
Ich habe noch genug Kohle, so am Start.
Und ich brauche nicht viel Geld, kommt auch dazu.
Ich kaufe mir keine super fetten Autos, Klamotten.
Oder sonst irgendwelche, habe ich irgendwelche super teuren Hobbys.
Ich kaufe mir ab und zu mal einen teuren Gaming-PC.
Ja, ich habe mir letztens tatsächlich mal ein Auto gekauft, seit 20 Jahren oder so.
Also schon lange her.
Und ich brauche nicht viel Geld, so.
Und jetzt kommt der wichtigste Punkt.
Warum ich dann nicht so viele Schmerzen habe ist,
naja, ich mache noch YouTube und Twitch und sonstige Sachen nebenbei,
wo ich Geld mit verdiene.
Das heißt, ich komme so schon über die Runden.
Und damit komme ich auf jeden Fall über die Runden.
Aber trotzdem, wie gesagt, ich kann es doch mal sagen,
habe ich im letzten Video auch gesagt,
Vollzeit-Content-Creator würde ich im Leben nicht machen wollen.
Was verdienst du so mit deinen Videos?
Sag ich gleich was zu, wenn ich im Chat bei der Frage bin.
Da reicht nicht.
Ich meine, wir haben ja letztens mal in dieser Spiegel-Statistik geguckt
mit Einnahmen und Geld und Vermögen.
Laut der Spiegel-Statistik, ja, würde das zu reich zählen,
aber ich fühle mich absolut nicht reich und ich bin nicht reich.
Ich habe keine goldenen BMWs oder so rumstehen oder so ein Bullshit.
Ich habe ganz normal Vermögen, Geld.
Das ist jetzt nicht, dass ich irgendwie im Geld schwimme.
Leider geht es vielen Leuten mittlerweile so schlecht,
dass der Durchschnitt so weit gesunken ist,
dass das fast schon reich ist, wenn es einem einfach normal geht.
Aber ich bin alles andere als reich.
Bei dir könnten solche Werbepartner auch als Satire...
Na ja, Satire wäre ja, wenn ich ein Placement mache
und dafür kein Geld kriege und das verarsche.
Das ist schon ein echtes Placement, was ich mache.
Manscaped, ey, Manscaped, die haben, glaube ich,
mich sogar mal angeschrieben.
Soll ich mal suchen?
Das mache ich.
Man, man, man, man, man, man.
Man, man, man, man, man.
Man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man.
Man, man, man, man, man, man.
Man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man.
Das mache ich.
Manscaped.
Tatsächlich, die haben mich angeschrieben.
Okay, bei einer Sache wäre ich tatsächlich gespannt.
Kann man diese Manscaped-Dinger...
Also sind die nur für Intimrasur gedacht
oder sind die auch zum normalen Rasieren, ja?
Ich habe mir das nie angeguckt.
Ich habe so einen Allzweck, keine Ahnung,
25 Euro Amazon billig Trimmer für alles.
Aber gut, und da würde mich tatsächlich mal interessieren,
haben die einfach nur gute Werbung
oder können die wirklich irgendwas besser?
Als Bahn-Influencer, ja, das wäre es noch.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich gehe zur Bahn.
Wie soll das, wie soll sich das denn...
Also der einzige Weg, wie ich bei der Bahn anfangen könnte, ist,
wenn ich 100, aber garantiertes 100% Homeoffice habe
und nie mal wieder mit der Bahn irgendwo hinfahren müsste.
Anders könnte ich ja mein Geflame auf Twitter gar nicht im Zaum halten.
Und selbst dann fahre ich wahrscheinlich hobbymäßig,
wochenendtechnisch, so mal irgendwo hin oder so, irgendwann.
Die Bahn, nee, die Bahn hat mich nicht angeschrieben.
Mich hatte mal von der Bahn einer angeschrieben,
als ich ihre Mobile-App geflamt habe,
ob ich nicht mal in Frankfurt vorbeikommen will
und mir das angucken will,
als Bahn-Innovations-Center, aber nee, will ich nicht.
Du bekommst jetzt ein, wie spricht man das aus?
ID.3? Ist das VW, oder? Oder war es BMW?
VW, nee, VW.
Ja, die sind nice.
Sind die das mit dem Touch-Panel auf dem Lenkrad?
Das fand ich ja upturnend.
Agile Cloud Hyperscaler.
Diagonales Skalieren hast du noch vergessen.
Du baust eine neue Website für die Bahn. Nice.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß, es gucken manche Leute von der Bahn zu.
Was war das jetzt?
Angeblich hat irgendjemand das subscribt, kam gerade ein Zaun und dann doch nicht.
Cottbus 99 wahrscheinlich. Dankeschön.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Also wenn ich Leute flamee, wenn ich die Bahn flamee,
dann meine ich selbstverständlich nicht die normalen Leute,
die dort für die Bahn arbeiten,
auch nicht die Leute auf Twitter oder sowas.
Hab ich noch mehr Subs übersehen?
Jetzt rein gucken.
Ich schaue mal schnell.
Haben wir denn hier noch?
Disres1337, Massive.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Bist du als Externer da? Okay.
Die zahlen fair.
Du musst Externe ja auch fair bezahlen, sonst würden sie ja keine kriegen.
Leute, ich glaube, ich bin noch nie so oft Auto gefahren,
wie ich mit dem neuen Auto fahre.
Erstens macht es Spaß, mit dem Auto zu fahren.
Also Elektroauto ist schon was Nices, irgendwie hat schon was.
Und außerdem ist es neu.
Es hat viel mehr Technik drin als mein alter Agila,
was ich auch geil finde.
Moinsjell.
Vier Tage, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich gehe nie wieder Vollzeit arbeiten.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ach so, wenn ich 80k sage, muss ich sagen, dann gilt das für 5 Tage.
Da kann es noch 20% abziehen.
Für 4 Tage.
Wobei ich wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen mehr verlangen sollte,
dass nicht gar so viel abgezogen.
Weil 4 Tage, wenn man das dann abzieht, dann sieht es so günstig aus wieder.
Vielleicht sollte ich wirklich sagen 70k für 4 Tage.
Oder mal gucken.
Ich glaube, das ist die beste Taktik.
Zwischen Verlangen und bei den Läden Kriegen sind zwar unterschiedlich paar Schuhe.
Wenn ich einen super harten Crime machen würde,
würde ich eventuell eine Stelle finden, die das bezahlt.
Es gibt dann aber auch welche,
wo du dich wahrscheinlich übertrieben ins Zeug legen musst.
Weil die bezahlen es ja nicht just for fun.
Und ich mache das schon ordentlich, was ich mache.
So ist das nicht.
Aber auf jetzt no life habe ich auch keinen Bock.
Deswegen habe ich ja gesagt, das ist das Mindeste, wofür ich es machen würde.
Und das müssen die ja nicht wissen.
Ja, also was verdienst du so mit deinen Videos?
Da wollte ich was zu sagen.
Also das schwankt.
Das schwankt extrem.
Aus mehreren Gründen.
Das gilt übrigens nicht nur für mich,
sondern das gilt für alle Content Creator und die, die es werden wollen.
Also das schwankt extrem.
Das hängt an verschiedenen Sachen.
Das erste ist, Werbung, die man von YouTube geschaltet bekommt,
lohnt sich in der Regel nicht.
Das ist rein passiv, weil du kriegst es eh, sobald es aktiviert.
Also du wirst nicht reich, rein von dem Standard YouTube Werbeblock.
Es sei denn, du hast halt wirklich Millionen da Aufrufe.
Ja, da geht das bestimmt auch.
Aber unterm Strich, das bringt jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Wie viele Tabs du offen hast.
Hier 50, da nochmal irgendwie 30 und in der VM auch nochmal 30.
Also das bringt nicht so wahnsinnig viel und das schwankt extrem.
Du hast im Dezember rum CPM, also das ist quasi was du bekommst für 1000 Aufrufe.
1000 Aufrufe, die glaube ich potenziell die Werbung sehen könnten.
Die nicht unbedingt die Werbung gesehen haben müssen.
Das ist eine komische Regel.
Ich habe es bis heute nicht verstanden.
Die gehen dann teilweise hoch bis, was weiß ich, 20 CPM und sonst was.
Das geht übertrieben ab im Dezember vor Weihnachten.
Oder halt generell, wenn die Leute, in Monaten wo die Leute Geld ausgeben,
machen die Werbeplätze kriegen, gibt immer massig viel Geld.
Was ist in dem Chromium Ordner CACW?
Neuer Ordner ist da drin.
Und dann habe ich mir irgendwas gebookmarkt vom lokalen Stream.
Irgendwelche lokalen Links für den Stream gebookmarkt oder so.
Also das ist was, was schon mal im Jahr extrem schwankt.
Das muss einem klar sein im Thema Content Creation und Geld damit verdienen.
Und das zweite ist, warum es extrem schwankt.
Gerade wenn man sich Twitch Subscriptions anguckt,
die sind natürlich auch in Monaten wo die Leute daheim sind und Geld ausgeben höher.
Im Dezember hat man in der Regel die meisten Subscriber.
Aber selbst die schwanken ein bisschen.
Und ein weiterer Punkt, warum das ganze extrem schwankt ist.
Was hast du für Placements?
Also sprich gibt es gerade gute Placements?
Was was irgendwie passt?
Was was sich lohnt?
Was du bereit bist zu machen?
Das ist ja auch nicht jedes Mal gleich.
So.
Also ich kann dir sagen, ich habe...
Ja, ach so, ja.
Und da gibt es natürlich noch Affiliate Programme und sowas.
Da ist es ähnlich.
Und es gibt noch irgendwelche dauerhaften Sponsorings mit Key-Shops und sonst was.
Da ist es meistens ein fixer Betrag.
Aber je nachdem, was du da hast...
Nice, Dankeschön Leute.
Was auch immer mir Twitch damit sagen will.
Je nachdem, was du da hast, ist da auch ein recht hoher Affiliate-Anteil drin.
So.
Also im Endeffekt heißt das unterm Strich, du kannst dich da nicht wirklich drauf verlassen auf...
So konstantes, konstantes Einkommen.
Das schwankt immer.
Aber was ich dir sagen kann ist, ich will jetzt die genauen Zahlen nicht sagen, weil ich dir auch nicht sagen will, für was ich Sponsorings mache.
Also für das Genshin-Sponsoring.
Was 90 Sekunden ging, da wo ich erzählt habe, ich war noch nie in einer Wüste und sowas in der Richtung.
Für das Genshin-Sponsoring habe ich einen niedrigen vierstelligen Betrag gekriegt.
So.
Das ist wahrscheinlich bei anderen nichts.
Die stehen dafür wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr auf.
Aber ich denke für meinen Channel ist das durchaus in Ordnung.
Da geht je nachdem, was du siehst, ich hatte auch schon mal deutlich mehr.
Vor allem in Kombination mit Geld plus noch Hardware und sowas dabei.
Das war natürlich für mich immer das allerniceste.
Kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen drauf an, was es ist.
Also du kannst natürlich für irgendeinen 90 Sekunden Placement nicht so viel verlangen,
wie wenn du wirklich ein dedicated Video machst, wo du sagst, ich stelle dir jetzt mal was vor oder so.
Das muss natürlich mehr sein.
Aber das dedicated Video will ja kaum noch einer.
Aber wenn du zum Beispiel sagst, ich stelle euch jetzt mal 2-3 Minuten.
Zum Beispiel wenn ich sage, ich stelle euch jetzt mal den neuesten Hetzener Service vor oder so.
Das würde dann 2-3 Minuten gehen und ich würde wirklich dann auch was zeigen, was direkt damit zu tun hat,
was direkt die Leute bei mir anspricht.
Das ist natürlich dann wieder was anderes, als wenn ich 30 Sekunden sage,
hier lade dir dieses komische Pay2win-Mobile-Game runter.
Es schwankt.
Das hört sich jetzt, ich gebe zu, das hört sich alles auf den ersten Blick viel an,
aber ihr müsst mal überlegen, was du als Vollzeit-Content-Creator, was da alles dranhängt.
Nimm mal den ganzen Stress außen vor, den du hast, dass du Content produzieren musst, ob du willst oder nicht.
Und Vollzeit-Content-Creator, jetzt, man darf sich da nicht die einzelnen Leute angucken,
die da durch quasi mega reich geworden sind, die quasi einen Furz lassen können und 3 Millionen Aufrufe haben.
Das meine ich nicht, so die Mittelklasse der Content-Creator, also die Riesenmehrheit der Content-Creator,
die arbeiten da wirklich ziemlich viel am Tag für.
Viele streamen stundenlang, machen Videos stundenlang, die sind den ganzen Tag mehr oder weniger mit ihrem Content-Kram beschäftigt
und das hört man vielen teilweise auch nach dem, wo manche Leute jetzt aufhören zu arbeiten, nicht auf.
Und viel Pause dazwischen ist es nicht. Klar, für viele ist es keine wirkliche Arbeit,
weil das quasi das ist, was sie halt total gerne machen wollen, aber das ist nicht, das darf man nicht unterschätzen.
Und dementsprechend sind jetzt auch, wenn man sagt 1500 oder 1200 oder 2000 Euro oder was auch immer für den Sponsoring,
sagen wir 2000 Euro für den Sponsoring, hört sich jetzt viel an, aber überlegt euch mal,
wie viele Sponsorings der Typ machen müsste, so der Mittelklasse Content-Creator,
dass der auf einen normalen Monatslohn überhaupt kommt.
Ich meine, wie gesagt, es ist nicht nur Sponsoring, da kommt ganz viel Zeug dabei, von Affiliate-Programmen bis Twitch-Subscripts und so weiter.
Aber überlegt euch mal, einer, der wirklich nur Sponsorings macht, wie viele Sponsorings müsste der im Monat machen?
Im Jahr machen? Schwachsinn, nicht im Monat. Wie viele Sponsorings muss der im Jahr machen?
Der müsste vorneweg 20 Sponsorings im Jahr machen. Also sagen wir mal 2 Sponsorings im Monat.
Und dann musst du halt aufpassen, du kannst ja auch nicht deinen kompletten Channel nur noch zum Sponsoring-Placement-Shit machen,
zumal das müsste es dann auch erst mal passendes geben. Also ganz so einfach ist das gar nicht, wie man sich das oftmals vorstellt.
Und auch wenn sich jetzt viel anhört, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie was Vierstelliges, wie gesagt, andere stehen dafür gar nicht auf,
in der Summe ist das jetzt auch nicht so, dass ich davon jetzt, wie gesagt, den goldenen BMW kaufen kann morgen.
Muss auch mal ein, ich hab grad aus irgendwelchen Gründen Datenbank gelesen, frag mich nicht.
Ich muss auch mal einen deutschen Bahnhörn ablassen. Bei mir in NRW im Rhein-Ruhr-Kreis geht mir DB so sehr derbe auf den Sack,
ja nicht nur da, die geht allen überall auf den Sack. Du willst zur Uni fahren, musst 1-2 Stunden früher aufstehen,
weil die Kackbahnen alle 30-60 Minuten random zwischendurch weitere 30 Minuten Verspätung waren.
Ja, wo wir gerade dabei sind, passt mal auf, Hanau, Verspätung hab ich heute, kam heute sogar in die News irgendwo.
Äh, nope. Wie heißt diese komische, vor Sprung oder so?
Ja, da kam mal sogar irgendwo, das wird mir manchmal auf dem Tablet empfohlen, frag mich nicht,
ich weiß nicht, was das für eine Seite ist. Da stand heute wieder drinnen, Bahn fällt aus.
Das ist irgendwas hier, Hanau und Region News. Kam gleich wieder, Hanau, Bahn fällt aus.
Oder muss ich vielleicht nach Zug suchen? Vollsperrung immer, blablabla, also voll für den Arsch.
Mein Zug fährt wahrscheinlich die ganze Woche nicht, weil Personalmangel, also wirklich richtiger, richtiger Drecksladen.
Massive, Dankeschön für die 5 Euro, wobei ich bekomme gar keine 5 Euro, du hast Besos zur Hälfte mitfinanziert.
Aber trotzdem, nice Subscription.
Bahn macht 100% Homeoffice, ok, das ist gut. Ich mein, die wollen ja auch, dass die Leute ankommen bzw. die Leute was arbeiten und die wissen genau, wenn die Leute mit der Bahn fahren müssen, wird das nix.
Cottbus 990, Massive Subscriptions hier wieder.
Silver Cross, Dankeschön, 7 Monate, McFly, 22 Monate, Dankeschön Leute.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Was ich mir geholt hab, du meinst das Auto, ich hab mir ein Fiat 500e geholt.
Den da.
Fiat 500e.
Ja
So sieht er ungefähr so sieht er so sieht er aus ja
40 stunden wird es auch nie wieder arbeiten ja ich kann es jedem nur empfehlen dass ich es irgendwie leisten kann
Der jetzt nicht irgendwie den wahnsinns haus kredit oder was auch immer bei mir auf der arbeit einer hat hat mir erzählt
Weil wir hatten es von teilzeit und sonst was einer auf der arbeit hat mir erzählt
Also weil ich habe eben das auch versucht schmackhaft zu machen mit teilzeit habe gesagt alle glaubt mir das ist das das erholsamste was zu machen kannst
Und da meint er kann sich das finanziell nicht leisten habe ich ihn gefragt warum und dann meinte ja haus kredit abbezahlen
Und ja okay haus kredit abbezahlen
Wann habt ihr denn das haus abbezahlt und dann meint er allen ernst ist wenn ich in rennte gehe
Das hat er ohne scheiß war habt ihr das haus abbezahlt da meint er doch wenn ich in rennte gehe
Der ist ein bisschen jünger als ich also sagen wir mal der ist dreißig
Der muss jetzt allen ernstes 40 jahre das haus abbezahlen mann
40 jahre ich weiß nicht immer was in fünf jahren ist
Fünf jahren ist ich würde im leben kein kredit für 40 jahre abschließen
Im leben nicht ja ich habe echt glück dass ich eins geerbt habe ja
Na ja dann würde ich mir gar kein haus holen ganz ehrlich 40 jahre kredit überlegt euch mal überlegt euch was da alles dran hängt
Wahrscheinlich hat das ja er mit seiner frau zusammen an der backe oder mit seiner freundin ich weiß nicht ob die verheiratet sind
Und kind und alles jetzt überlegt euch mal wenn die sich trennen in
vier fünf jahren
Der ist gefickt für sein ganzes leben
Allein schon aus dem grund würde ich das nicht also naja also ihr wisst wie ich das meine finanziell
Ja an der weite ich dann eher nicht mehr aber trotzdem das kannst du vergessen
Da bist du bist geliefert
Also deswegen ich würde ich würde kann ich muss auch ehrlich sagen ich habe noch nie
Ein kredit abgeschlossen ich lasse mal überlegen nicht dass ich jetzt lüge es gibt ja auch so manchmal so
So so dinge wo du gar nicht so richtig mit kriegst aber aber ich habe wissentlich
Noch nie einen kredit abgeschlossen was damit was damit zu tun hat ich habe das immer so gehandhabt
Entweder habe ich die kohle oder nicht welche kohle nicht habe habe ich gekauft und wenn ich die kohle habe habe ich gekauft
Und mir ist auch klar dass das nicht bei allem funktioniert manche sagen gehen halt nicht anders
Okay, dass ich mir gefallen und ich rede von privaten sachen ja jetzt nicht leute die für ihr geschäft was aufnehmen das mag das mag alles
was anderes sein
Aber ansonsten ich würde ich würde nie kredite aufnehmen vor allem nicht in dieser höhe
Wenn ich die kohle fürs auto nicht gab der hätte ich mir kein auto gekauft
Es ist ja nicht so als gäbe es nicht auch billigere autos
Habe ich schon gezeigt digga was geht ich bin ziemlich im arsch heute geht nicht allzu viel
Digga
Das ding in den ferien arbeiten ich habe auch nicht in den ferien gearbeitet beinahe stimmt nicht
Aber man war das in den
Gearbeitet kann man das nicht wirklich nennen ich habe mal pakete gepackt in den ferien zu so einem versand
Versand lager war so
Versanddinger
Habe ich mal pakete gepackt in den ferien früher habe ich einmal gemacht und nie wieder
Seitdem kann ich relativ schnell mit so einem
Roller weiß gar nicht wie die dinger heißen diese paket klebeband roller kann ich relativ schnell ein paket zumachen
Zack zack zack das ding zu ich glaube das könnte ich heute noch
Ich glaube das könnte ich heute noch
Was in den fern arbeiten ist halt auch nicht so cool in der zehn war der unterschied mega von kah wieviel ha die
Woche in der schule sitzen zu
Alter, was ist das für ein Satz? Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was du mir sagen willst.
In der Zehnten war der Unterschied mega.
Von, keine Ahnung, wie viel Stunden die Woche in der Schule sind.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich es. Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Okay, es liegt nicht an dir, es liegt an mir.
Ähm, von keine Ahnung, wie viele Stunden die Woche in der Schule sind, zu 40 Stunden die Woche hart körperlich arbeiten.
Oh ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das ein Riesenunterschied ist.
Zwischen vielleicht nicht, was sage ich?
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Aber es gibt auch, es gibt auch den umgedrehten Fall.
Ich habe mir vor nicht allzu langer Zeit einen neuen Zaun bauen lassen, einen kleinen.
Nur zwischen Hof und Garten.
Und also nicht den kompletten Garten lang, sondern wirklich nur diese Strecke, Hof, die Grenze.
Im Prinzip war es eigentlich nur eine neue Tür.
Mit ein bisschen Zaun drumherum.
Neuen Zaun bauen lassen und ich habe mit dem Typ geredet, der den Zaun gebaut hat und der meinte, er hat früher einen Bürojob gehabt.
Und er hat es nicht ausgehalten im Bürojob.
Und jetzt, Leute, Schwachsinn, nicht, das war nicht der Typ, der den Zaun gebaut hat.
Das war der Typ, der die Bäume geschnitten hat im Garten.
Ist letztendlich aber auch egal.
Hat gemeint, er hatte vorher einen Bürojob gehabt und er hat es dann nicht ausgehalten.
Und jetzt, was weiß ich, wie der Beruf heißt, wahrscheinlich so Landschaftsbauer, Landschaftsgärtner oder sowas.
Hab ich gelabert mit dem, als er im Garten war und am Baum rumgeschnibbelt hat.
Und er meinte, das ist der beste Job, den er sich vorstellen kann.
Da ist er den ganzen Tag unterwegs, hat den ganzen Tag was zu tun und am Ende weiß er, was er geschafft hat.
Also kommt es immer auf den Typ selbst an.
Sample Name.
Zero.
Ganz wichtig.
Zwei Monate, Dankeschön.
Da ich gefühlt eine 60-Stunden-Woche mit Hausaufgaben und Lernen habe.
Naja, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, oder?
Ich meine, wer zwingt dich, Einser zu schreiben?
Kannst du einfach Dreier und Vierer schreiben?
Dann musst du nicht so viel lernen.
Easy.
Das musst du später auf der Arbeit auch noch lernen.
Du darfst nicht immer umsonst alles machen.
Du musst die Sachen effektiv machen.
Du musst die Sachen so erledigen, dass sie gut erledigt sind und dich keiner mehr damit nervt.
Aber du darfst nicht alles umsonst machen.
Warum sollten die dir sonst mehr bezahlen, wenn du alles freiwillig umsonst machst?
Das erzählen sie dir immer.
Du musst erst mal zeigen, dass du es verdient hast, mehr Geld zu bezahlen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
So funktioniert das nicht.
Get on Wooplos Match.
Leute, ich war ein paar Mal davor, mit manchen Shops was abzuschließen.
Gerade jetzt, wo ich die ganzen neuen Kekse habe.
Leute, der Goldkeks mit Kette, der ist so nice.
Den brauche ich eigentlich unbedingt auf dem T-Shirt.
Es gebe schon coole Sachen, die man machen könnte.
Aber ich habe bis jetzt noch nichts gefunden, wo ich mit einverstanden wäre.
Also insofern, nope, wird es wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit auch nicht geben.
Kreisel Cry Merch.
Also es gibt wirklich coole Sachen.
Aber ich habe noch nichts gefunden.
Ich habe mich einige Shops angeschrieben schon, ob ich was machen will.
Also es war bisher noch nichts wirklich überzeugendes dabei.
Ja, zumindest eine Sache, da lege ich Wert drauf.
Also wenn es schon Wooplos und Max FPS Merchandise gibt, also es muss dann irgendwelche T-Shirts
und sonst was auch immer sein, dann sollte das zumindest unter normalen Bedingungen hergestellt
sein.
Also ich will nicht, dass irgendwelche Kinder aus Bangladesch das Wooplos T-Shirt nehmen.
Also das müssen die mir dann schon in irgendeiner Art und Weise darlegen können, was sie da
für Zeug haben.
Ihr wisst, ich mag Menschen nicht, aber ich will trotzdem nicht, dass Kinder aus Bangladesch
oder Vietnam meine T-Shirts nähen.
Jeezy Pro, 16 Monate, Dankeschön für den mega huge Subscription.
Malaysische Kinder, die auch nicht, auch keine China-Chinesen-Kinder oder auch keine Nordkoreaner,
die ja neunigst in China arbeiten müssen.
Natürlich ist das Arbeit, das wird Arbeit ab dem Zeitpunkt, ich kann es dir genau sagen,
ab wann das Arbeit wird, das wird ab dem Zeitpunkt Arbeit, wo du es machen musst, weil du finanziell
darauf angewiesen bist und keinen Bock an dem Tag hast, dann wird es zur Arbeit.
Und mit Sicherheit hat jeder Streamer und jeder Content-Creator Tage, wo er keinen Bock
hat, aber trotzdem ran muss, weil das sein Job ist, ist das Arbeit, selbstverständlich
ist das Arbeit.
Hast du schon von der neuen Next.js Version gehört?
Nö.
Ich bin aber auch kein Reakt-Benutzer, keine Ahnung, was die da treiben.
Gibt es bestimmt ein Fireship-Video, oder?
Gibt es ein Fireship-Video?
Wenn es ein Fireship-Video gibt, gucken wir uns das gleich noch an, die sind gut.
Wir streamen noch ein bisschen, bis 22 Uhr, willst du mal einen Reakt probieren, ehrlich
gesagt nicht?
Wenn ich Frontend-Sachen mache, dann ist das Svelte oder Vue noch ein drittes Frontend-Framework,
keine Ahnung, dann gucke ich mir lieber eines der neuen Hype-Dinger an, von Astro bis Quick
oder sonst was.
Leute, Dankeschön für den Sub, wir Luchs, ich lese euch alle vorher, ich bin nur ein
bisschen lahm im Chat gerade.
Du hast recht, oft kann die Bahn nichts dafür, das ist richtig, aber die Bahn könnte sich
so aufstellen, dass Kleinigkeiten nicht so große Auswirkungen haben.
Sie bekommen Ärger, wenn sie wegen der Bahn zu spät kommen, die können sich einfach mal
ficken gehen bei der Bahn, ich würde im Leben nichts, doch 100% Remote würde ich bei der
Bahn vielleicht sogar arbeiten.
Ganz im Ernst, das ist so eine Sache, die würde ich tatsächlich Just For Fun einfach
gerne mal ausprobieren.
Vorstellungsgespräch mit der Bahn, irgendwie ist der Sound ziemlich kaputt gerade oder?
Es macht immer blub blim und dann kommt nix, ich glaube, das ist broken.
Das müssen wir mal machen, wirklich Just For Fun, sich bei der Bahn bewerben, Vorstellungsgespräch
machen, ne Viertelstunde zu spät kommen und sagen, sorry Leute, mein Zug war nicht, aber
ihr habt da bestimmt Verständnis für.
Da habe ich keine Ahnung von, aber es scheint mir jetzt irgendwie unsinnig, Kredit aufzunehmen,
ohne ihn abzubezahlen.
Ich weiß nicht, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das dann so easy funktioniert, das ist
ja auch ziemliches Investment ins Plaue, nur weil das aktuell geht, heißt es nicht, dass
es in 30 Jahren noch geht, das wären 40 Jahre, da kannst du doch überhaupt nichts abschätzen.
Naja, wäre ja auch okay, wenn ich dann alles, was ich bräuchte und haben will, so gestellt
bekommen würde, aber solange das nicht der Fall ist, ist das, ich meine, es passiert
schon erstaunlich wenig, was mir wichtig ist von meinen Steuern, das ist schon schlecht
genug.
Ja, Leasing-Karren war ich jetzt auch nicht so der Wahnsinns-Fan von, ich hab mir das
ja auch mal angeguckt beim neuen Auto, muss doch vieles achten.
Ich hab's aber schon wieder vergessen, zumindest fand ich es nicht so toll, für mich privat.
Da kann ich dir nur recht geben, im IT-Bereich zu arbeiten ist tatsächlich eines der besten
Sachen, man muss aber sagen, in vielen Bereichen ist es tatsächlich ganz gut, man muss sich
das auch mal handwerkertechnisch angucken, ich glaube dort, ich mein, wie sagt man so
schön, willst du ja keine goldene Nase dran verdienen, also du wirst jetzt nicht super
reich, werde ich ja dadurch auch nicht im Endeffekt hier im IT-Bereich, aber du kannst
glaube ich heute als Handwerker auch gut Geld verdienen, wenn du weißt, was du machst.
Es wird so händeringend überall Leute gesucht, vom Elektriker, also alles eigentlich, zum
Zaunbauer.
Bist du energieautark mit einer Photovoltaik im Aus, ne noch nicht und ich weiß noch nicht,
ob ich das mache, aktuell ist es eh saumäßig schwierig was zu bekommen, es ist sehr teuer
geworden und wenn überhaupt, dann wird es auch eine recht teure Installation, was ich
wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit auch nicht wirklich rechnet, das muss ich mir tatsächlich
überlegen, ob ich da nochmal 15 oder 20.000 Euro in die Hand nehmen will und da mein Dach
per Photovoltaiken möchte, also da bin ich tatsächlich noch unentschlossen, ob ich das
wirklich machen will, aktuell kannst du es eh vergessen, weil du nichts kriegst und keine
Leute findest, die es machen.
Wie findet man als Student einen Job als Werkst- ich habe keine Ahnung, chat, das müsst
ihr wissen, in der Situation war ich nicht, wahrscheinlich findet man aber als Student
einen Job auf die gleiche Art und Weise, wie man überall anders einen Job findet, gucken
wo es Jobs gibt und schauen ob die Studenten nehmen, weil bei uns, also ich weiß bei uns
auf der Seite steht zum Beispiel dabei in den Jobanzeigen, dass wir duale Studenten
suchen und was auch immer noch alles und ich weiß nicht wie es da bei LinkedIn ist, ob
man da Angebote für kriegt, wahrscheinlich eher nicht, aber da kann man bestimmt auch
gucken, aber ansonsten kann ich da nichts raten, kein Plassen-Schimmer.
Älteste, Dankeschön, Subscription, 3 Monate, Merci.
Also, weil es ja eben hieß, Content Creator und so ist alles keine Arbeit, also ich arbeite
4 Tage die Woche, also sind das schon mal, na gut es sind nicht ganz, ich glaube ich
arbeite 30 Stunden, weiß gar nicht genau, ich glaube es sind 30 Stunden, 30,5 oder irgendwie
sowas ja, also ich arbeite 30 Stunden normal, so, ich streame und produziere Videos für
YouTube und das kostet mir sicherlich auch nochmal 20 Stunden, wenn es reicht die Woche.
Jetzt kommt natürlich eine Ansage, streamen ist keine Arbeit und so wie ich das mache
ist es auch in dem Ausmaß sicherlich ziemlich irgendwie schlauchend und so und ich kann
es auch, ich mache es auch nur wenn ich Bock drauf habe oder wenn es mir danach ist, aber
trotzdem, das ist immerhin Zeit, die man in was reinsteckt, die man nicht für was
anderes verwenden kann und wie man nicht weiß, ich habe 20 Stunden da ausreichend, ich meine
guck mal, wenn ich 3 Stunden on bin in einem Stream, 200-300, da ist das mal ganz schnell
das Radfahrzweck, also man bräuchte teilweise echt mehr Zeit am Tag, so 48 Stunden Tag oder
so wäre ganz gut, wenn ich etwas, achso das ist der Bot, ich weiß nicht was das für
eine Seite ist, aber die klicke ich nicht an, das klingt nach XXXXX, Cheesy Pro Massive
Subscription hier, wieder, TSFUX1 12 Monate, du hast den Gold Kicks erworben jetzt, Pog,
die China-Chinesen klauen das Design, tja, das wird mich nicht wundern, gibt es dann
Max FPS, Merch demnächst bei Aliexpress, Velux, Dankeschön für den Sub, oder ne, es ist
eher Velux, oder, ach das gibt ein Fireship Video zu, ok man, Fireship YouTube, wie heißt
das Ding, Next.js, Next oder ne, ach da ist es ja, Next.js, können wir uns gleich angucken,
keine Angular-Enjoyer, ne da bin ich, ich bin Teams Weltkit und Team Vue.js, ich bin
kein Angular-Enjoyer, hast du mal was mit Kotlin gemacht, nein, der Ton knackt, wirklich,
Sekunde, nicht dass hier wieder was am abkacken ist, der Ton knackt, knackt der Ton, was
am abkacken ist, der Ton knackt, knackt, knackt nix, keck, Leute, knackt der Ton bei euch,
ich hab grad ans Mikrofon gegriffen, deswegen hat es geknackt. Solle.js oder eines der 30
Milliarden anderen Framework, die es gibt. Ähm, Astro wollte ich mir eh mal angucken.
Ok, ok, ok, ok.
Der hat auch sonst nichts mehr gemacht, oder?
24 Stunden arbeiten, das darf man in Deutschland gar nicht 24 Stunden arbeiten.
Du darfst, glaube ich, maximal nur 11 Stunden oder so am Stück und dann musst du,
nee, nee, du musst mindestens 11 Stunden Pause haben zwischen Ende und Beginn.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das ist. Du darfst überhaupt keine 24 Stunden arbeiten.
Nee, Quick gucke ich mir auch nicht an. So, okay, ich habe den Chat durch, zeig mal
her. Also, neues... Moment, wo ist das Video?
Neues Fireship-Video, nein. Wo habe ich denn jetzt offen hier?
Leute, ich blicke nicht mehr durch, zu viel. Hier, Fireship, da. Zu viel, zu viel Zeug.
Es ist zu viel. Leute, ich habe zu viele Tabs auf. Ich weiß ja nicht mal, wo der Sound
gerade an ist hier. Was ist denn das hier? Können wir zumachen?
Ja, wir machen mal alles, was hier offen ist, machen wir alles zu.
Alles, was nicht YouTube ist, wo man vielleicht gucken wollte, alles zu.
Auch zu. Einschlafmusik, ja, die lassen wir auf.
Ja, genau, 11 Stunden Ruhezeit, das habe ich nämlich auch im Kopf.
Das Cackle. Cackle.js, Leute, wie wäre es damit?
Ich glaube, das haben wir gebraucht. Warte mal. Nicht, dass es das schon gibt.
Okay, nee, anscheinend nicht. Gibt es Cackw.js? Okay, Cackw.js scheint es schon zu geben,
aber Cackle.js gibt es noch nicht. Wie sieht es mit einem Stream aus? Ganz im
Moment. Ich kann das Spiel nicht lange am Stück spielen. Das regt mich auf. Das wird im Stream
nicht anders sein. Ich werde ein bisschen Offstream spielen,
aber der Multiplayer, also die Beta hat mich schon nicht sonderlich gecatcht. Ich weiß
nicht. Vielleicht, vielleicht gucke ich mir mal wieder Warzone an, wenn es da draus ist.
Ich habe hier relativ viel Warzone gespielt vor drei oder zwei Jahren, als es noch recht
neu war. Kampagne ist schon raus, die kann man jetzt theoretisch sogar schon spielen.
Vielleicht gucke ich mir Warzone 2 an und vielleicht ist es geil und ich spiele es tatsächlich
mal wieder eine Weile. Also, wenn ihr mich fragt, sollen sie es legal
machen. Ich weiß eh nicht, warum das so lange dauert. Haben das die Grünen nicht sogar
während der Wahl im Wahlprogramm versprochen, dass das legal wird?
Tragt ihr eine Knirscherschiene? Das ist sowas, dass man nachts nicht schnarcht, oder?
Nee, das ist nicht, dass man nachts nicht schnarcht. Was erzähle ich für ein Blödsinn?
Natürlich ist das nicht, dass man nachts nicht mit die Zähne so aufeinander macht. Ich trage
keine Knirscherschiene. Das einzige, was ich nachts tragen musste
früher, war Zahnspange. Und ich hatte zwischenzeitlich so diese
richtig abfack Zahnspange. Kennt ihr das, wo du so einen Metallgestell
nachts anhaben musst? Warte mal, Zahnspange, Metallgestell, ich
weiß nicht, sowas da, sowas da, so ein Ding, what the fuck ist das, so ein Ding, das musste
ich mal für ein Jahr anziehen nachts. Alter, ich sag euch, was ein Schrott, so ein Teil
hier. Richtig räudig.
Voll, ja wirklich so, das musste ich nachts anziehen und die wollten das machen. Guckt
euch das an, die wollten, dass man darauf schläft und damit konntest du dich gar nicht
richtig auf die Seite drehen und sowas. Das war nix, musste ich zum Glück nicht lange
anziehen und ist schon ganz, ganz lange her. Ich weiß noch, als ich fertig war mit der
Zahnspange, da meinte damals der Kieferorthopäde, die wohl auch zufälligerweise so ne, wie nennt
man das, so Zahnschirurgie machen, meinte, ich sollte mir unbedingt jetzt gleich irgendwie
noch diesen Zahn ziehen lassen, weil ansonsten hätte ich in ein paar Jahren richtig viel
Probleme. Leute, soll ich euch was sagen, die paar Jahre sind um, ich hab mir den Zahn
nicht ziehen lassen und ich hab kein einziges Problem bisher damit gehabt. Der wollte wahrscheinlich
einfach nur ein bisschen Money verdienen da dran. Kann man damit auch Radio empfangen.
Ich geh mal davon aus, ja, wenn du da den passenden Connector dran machst, würdest du
wahrscheinlich paar Frequenzen reinkriegen. So, also wir wollen uns das Fireship Video
angucken. NextJS13, this changed everything. Das ist ja fast schon wie ein Level Cap Titel.
Level Cap erzählt doch auch immer. Massive new changes. This new Battlefield Patch is
a real game changer. Huge new update. Was ist das? Virtualized Server? Guck ich mir
immer gerne an, was andere Leute bei sich daheim so bauen. Warum schreibt der Nightbot
XD, weil er lustig sein will. XD, XD halt. Hast du noch Weisheitsszene? Nein, mittlerweile
nicht mehr. Ich hab die Weisheitsszene rausbekommen recht spät. Das müsste so 2000, 2000, 8
oder 9 gewesen sein. Ja, also mit 25 oder so. Ja, aber seitdem hab ich und ich hatte
nur oben Weisheitsszene. Unten hab ich keine gehabt. Ich hatte nur oben Weisheitsszene
und Fun Fact am Rande. Fun? Naja, so Fun ist das für mich nicht gewesen. Ich muss
das mal kurz erzählen. Ich hatte Weisheitsszene nur oben. Es wird zum Glück erspannt geblieben
unten die auch rauszumachen. Ich hab mich da auch relativ lange vor gedrückt, aber
irgendwann musste das einfach sein. Wär zu eklig. Zumindest mussten die dann raus und
ich hab, wie nennt man das, Kiefer-Chirurg-Praxis, haben wir einen Termin ausgemacht. Damals
hat der Typ noch gemeint, ja wir können das auch ruhig unter der Woche machen. Wir können
das ja auch für sie günstig terminieren. Also ich hab ihm erzählt nach dem Motto, wie
lange wird man danach krankgeschrieben und er meint, ja ein paar Tage sind das schon.
Und dann meint er zu mir, ja dann terminieren wir das doch günstig unter der Woche, so dass
das dann auch sich genau ausgeht. Hab ich mir gesagt, ok, dann terminieren wir das günstig
unter der Woche, sodass ich schön ne Woche krank sein kann. Also war ich ne Woche krank
und Leute ich sag euch, Weisheitszene raus war richtig beschissen. Nicht weil zu groß
geschwollen war oder so danach, sondern, das haltet euch fest, sowas hattet ihr nämlich
wahrscheinlich nicht. Links oben gar kein Problem, ging easy raus. Rechts oben musste
er ewig dran rum machen und dann hat sich nachher auch rausgestellt warum. Der Zahn
war halt nur ein Stück raus und steckte total tief im Oberkiefer drinnen und nachdem er
den Zahn rausgezogen hat, hatte ich ein Loch im Knochen. Ich hatte ein Loch zwischen Mund
und tja, Luftgängen von der Nase. Also ihr habt ja Nase und oben, ne bei der Nase gehen
da dann so ganz viele, also euer Schädel ist ja hohl zum größten Teil, sonst wär
er nicht so leicht. Da hatte ich ein Loch quasi zwischen hinten oben, da wo der Zahn
drin war, ein Loch zwischen Mund und Nase, könnte man sagen. Das war komisch, ich konnte
nämlich zum Beispiel quasi durch den Mund atmen, ohne den Mund dabei aufzumachen und
sowas. Es war ganz komisch. Hab ich mal hochgeladen, stimmt hab ich was zu erzählen. Das war eklig.
Waschi, du musst keine Gedanken machen, das haben nur ganz wenige Leute. Die Chancen,
dass du das hast, sind äußerst gering, du bist wahrscheinlich, bei dir ist wahrscheinlich
easy blob und raus. Genau, dann wurde das zugenäht, desinfiziert nochmal, zugenäht, mit extra
super sicher zugenäht. Leute, ich sah aus wie ein Vampir danach. Ich lag da, der hat
irgendwie noch eine halbe Stunde an mir rum, extra nochmal, was weiß ich, 45 Minuten an
mir rum genäht, ein paar Tage später, als ich das gemerkt hab. Und das hab ich gar
nicht im Video erzählt. Das ist eigentlich auch ganz witzig. Zumindest, ich lag da, der
hat 40, 45 Minuten an mir rum gemacht, das hat wehgetan, trotz Betäubung, weil das war
schon ein bisschen entzündet oben, der hat das desinfiziert und das war wirklich nicht
schön. Das hat wehgetan, das hat geblutet und der hat das zugenäht und meint dann auch
keinen Druck drauf machen und dann war das fertig, dann war das fertig und der fährt
mich hoch auf dem Sitz, ich steh auf und dann meinte die Zahnarzthelferin noch, ich weiß
nicht ob sie sie oder du gesagt hat, keine Ahnung, weiß nicht genau, hat sie mir gesagt,
sie sehen ja aus wie ein Vampir und hat mir ein Stück Papier gegeben und in dem Moment
mir passiert sowas normalerweise nie. Vielleicht lag sie auch an einem schönen Laden der Zahnarzthelferin,
keine Ahnung. Aber ich nehm das Papier von der und auf einmal wird es mir komplett schwarz
vor Augen. Ich lag 45 Minuten über Kopf da und bin halt gerade aufgestanden. Mir wird
schwarz vor Augen. Und das nächste was ich da mitgekriegt hab ist, dass ich halt so halb
an der Wand gehockt hab und die Zahnarzthelferin hat mich quasi so halb festgehalten. Das war
nicht lang, keine Ahnung, 10 Sekunden oder so vielleicht, das war zu viel. Das Aufstehen
nach 45 Minuten auf dem Kopf war einfach zu viel. Ich wollte nur festgehalten werden,
fest, exposed, exposed. Nope, 45 Minuten hat er noch mal extra genäht, da ging richtig
ab. Super ordentlich gemacht und danach durfte ich nicht belasten irgendwie ein paar Wochen
was mir sehr schwer gefallen ist. So jetzt gucken wir ja noch das Video. Fireship, auf
gehts. Nein, oh mann ich find das Video schon wieder nicht. Da, da ist es. Hast du ihre
Nummer bekommen? Nee. Ich hab auch nicht gefragt, da hatte ich andere Probleme. Ich glaube die
Fed hat jetzt auch Weirdchamp gefunden. Ey ich wollt jetzt noch was anderes erzählen,
das hebe ich mir aber mal auf. So, also wir gucken uns jetzt den Code Report an. Auf gehts.
Ah, never, niemals, niemals kann man Web Development all figured out haben. Da kommt jede Woche
jeden Tag was neues. Ganz im Ernst wisst ihr wo ich wirklich froh drüber bin, dass
Webpack so langsam aber sicher Geschichte wird. So eine Frau, nein. Alter, ist ja gut
schreit ich hoch. Next.js 13. Sag mal das Logo sieht irgendwie aus wie Apple inspiriert
oder? Das könnte auch Apple Watch 13 sein, das Logo. Ist das etwa Written in Rust, Leute?
Sagt wirklich, ist das Written in Rust? Weil wir wissen alle, ist etwas nicht Written
in Rust, dann kann es prinzipiell nicht blazingly fast sein. Ist das wirklich? Ok, dann ist
ok. Written in Rust. Written in Rust. Oh, wenn ich dieses Logo sehe, Paints Champ.
Ah, blazingly fast Written in Rust. Ein richtiger Rust, Rustation ist das ja. Krustation Rustation.
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie die sich nennen. Ist das eine Computerstimme? Nee, der hört
sich wirklich so an. Moment, Moment, das hab ich jetzt nicht
gesehen. Ist Turbo repo jetzt das Buildtool? Nee, wie heißt das Buildtool? Ah, Turbo Pack
ist das Build und Turbo. Ok, jetzt hört es bei mir wieder auf. Wie wärs mal mit einem
China-Chinesen PC? Warum soll ich mir absichtlich Scam bei AliExpress kaufen? Nee, nee, Andreas,
das ist kein Witz. Die nennen sich ja wirklich so, die Rust Leute. Nicht so, die nennt Rust
Crustation. Das ist noch nicht mal ein Witz. Das ist wirklich, die nennen sich Krustentiere
quasi. Weil Rust diese komische Krabbe hat. Cringe, ich weiß. Aber ist so. Ok, weiter
im Text. Turbo repo mit Turbo Build. Ich hab schon wieder, hieß es denn jetzt Turbo Build
überhaupt? Wie hieß es denn jetzt? Ok, Turbo repo mit Turbo Build. Ah, Turbo Pack, nicht
Turbo Build, Mann. Schneller als Web Pack zu sein ist jetzt ja kein Problem. Ich auch.
Wetten, das hat schon über 3000 Sterne auf Github. Github, Turbo, Pack.
Ok. Aha, hier. What the fuck, Alter. Das ist drei Tage alt. Wie kannst du, wie kann
man das fucking, wie alt ist das? Ach nee, da ist auch Turbo Pack und Turbo repo drinne.
Ok, ok, alles klar. Das ist schon ein bisschen älter. Ok, das repo gibt es schon ein bisschen
länger, alles klar. Ja, ja, ok, ok, das ist nicht erst gestern entstanden.
Ja, und die haben keinen Bock, Written in Rust zu machen. Alter, was mit dem seinem
Kinn los? Das Kinn ist ja quasi noch vor der Brille. Das ist ja, was ich bei diesen Werbevideos
immer immer immer witzig finde. Ist gar nicht so, ist gar nicht so. Ich wollte gerade sagen,
die müssen in diesen Werbevideos immer super divers sein. Das ist wie bei dieser eine Microsoft
Werbung. Erinnert sich noch irgendjemand an die Microsoft Werbung, wo sie den Schwarzen
raus Photoshoppt haben, dass das, also es gab eine Werbung von Microsoft. Da saßen auch
so Leute um so einen Meeting Tisch rum und haben halt super Business geguckt. Und die
Werbung hat Microsoft halt für die gesamte Welt verwendet. Und die Werbung wollten sie
dann glaube ich auch in Polen verwenden oder irgendwo. Und da haben sie dann mit Photoshop
den Schwarzen, der am Tisch saß, raus Photoshoppt und haben da halt einen Weißen hingesetzt.
Und das Problem war nur, die haben die Finger vergessen. Das war dann ein Weißer am Tisch
mit schwarzen Fingern von Microsoft Photoshop. Weiß gar nicht, was ich da suchen soll. Nicht
Blackkit. Hier, das da, genau. Das da. Das ist da nicht, Moment, Moment Leute. Das ist
da nicht Blackfacing, sondern wie nennt sich das denn jetzt? Wie gibt's da, das Bild mein
ich, was ist eigentlich mit dieser Seite los, Mann? Ja, genau. Guck mal, der hat ne, der
hat jetzt, das ist das Original? Das ist das Original? Der Typ hat halt einfach, der Typ
hat halt einfach ne schwarze Hand. Black eracing ist das jetzt. Guck mal, die haben halt einfach
die Hand behalten. Das ist doch richtig schlecht. Die haben halt nur den Kopf und der Kopf ist
auch komplett falsch irgendwo. Ich würde sogar sagen, schon im Original sieht es fast
schon Photoshopped aus. Wie sind wir da jetzt drauf gekommen gerade? Weiß nicht. Achso,
die immer so versuchen super divers in diesen ganzen Meeting-Dinger zu sein. Was war im Original
jetzt unpassend? Na, die haben sich gedacht, für die Audience in Europa oder in Polen
war die Werbung, wirkt es halt wahrscheinlich nicht so alltäglich, wer da ein Schwarzer
am Tisch sitzt. Und dementsprechend haben sie Photoshopped. Das neue YouTube-UI ist doch
Pog. Oh, guck mal, sieht es jetzt anders aus? Moment, guck mal, das hat sich gerade gechanged.
Wait a minute, eben sah YouTube noch so aus. Guck du mal, guck du mal Leute, YouTube hat
gechanged. Wait, ne, jetzt ist... Hä? Jetzt ist es wieder. Hä? Okay. Fireship. See. Ja,
guck mal da. Achso, dass ich Daumen runter habe, liegt am Plugin, nicht irgendwie an YouTube.
Das liegt hier an diesem Plugin. Wo sieht man die Plugins? Ja, das liegt an Return YouTube
des Likes, dass das... Also ich muss sagen, das ist tatsächlich ganz okay. Viel geändert
hat sich da jetzt allerdings auch nicht. Im Prinzip immer noch das gleiche, ein bisschen
dunkler. Wir können es jetzt ja direkt vergleichen. Ich mein, so, bisschen dunkler, was ich persönlich
ganz gut finde, das grenzt sich wieder ein bisschen besser ab. Ansonsten hat sich ja
daneben wirklich viel getan. Glow? Ich sehe da kein Glow. Ein Glow am Rand? Die Video-Thumbnails
sind abgerundet. Tatsache. Und auch oben die Suchlage. Und das Logo ist... Ne, das Logo
ist das gleiche. Ja, ich finde, das ist tatsächlich ganz okay. Ist ja nur minimal. Das Update,
ja, ist ja nicht viel. Was, geh mal aufs Zahnrad? Du mein, hier? Ambient Mode. Wait a minute.
Okay, das finde ich nicht gut. Das blinkt einfach nur dumm.
Ne, das brauche ich nicht. Egal, wir gucken das jetzt. Wir gucken jetzt mal das Video
fertig.
Ich habe mein Dark Reader auf YouTube aus.
Die View-Zeit ist versteckt? Nö. Ach, Moment, das ist ja das alte noch, zeig mal her.
Ne, hier. Das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, dass man das jetzt ausklappen muss. Das ist
okay. Okay, jetzt kommt irgendwelche React-Gramm, wo ich gar keinen Plan von habe. War es das
vorher nicht? War es nicht directory-based? Anscheinend nicht. Ne.
Es
Das erinnert mich an's Weltkit, die haben doch jetzt auch sowas gemacht.
Dennis, da hast du recht!
Dennis, das kann ich mir auch vorstellen.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Ich sehe jetzt schon 5 offene Tabs, die alle per HGS heißen.
Gut, meistens haben die ja den Subfolder noch irgendwie im Navi.
Ja, aber das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen.
Ich habe keinen Plan, was da eigentlich gerade passiert, weil ich keine Ahnung von React habe.
Ok, Sekunde, Sekunde, mal gucken, ob ich das hinkriege.
Also, Server-Side-Generation, Server-Side-Rendering, ist das Server-Side-Generation überhaupt?
Und das ist, was ist ISR?
Internet Super Router.
Ach, nicht Server-Side, Static-Side-Generation.
Interrupt Service Routine, ja, das stimmt, aber das meint er damit wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was Servers, Incremental Server, keine Ahnung.
Frontenzeug.
Leute, ich weiß, was wir als nächstes programmieren.
Ein Cache der Seiten, Cache, die es noch gar nicht gegeben hat.
Easy Money, Startup ist gegründet.
Ein Future Cache sozusagen.
Ein AI Cache.
Machine Learning Cache.
Der cached schon im Voraus Sachen, die bis jetzt noch keiner angefragt hat.
Hi-Fetch-Shit-Down.
Wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist, dass das wahrscheinlich zum Teil heutzutage funktioniert?
Negative Latency Cache, genau.
Das hat Internet, ja, das ist richtig.
Das machen CPUs schon lange.
Und das ist, was ich jetzt schon lange nicht gesehen habe.
Das ist, was ich jetzt schon lange nicht gesehen habe.
Das hat Internet, ja, das ist richtig.
Das machen CPUs schon lange.
Okay, ich bin komplett lost, ich hab keine Ahnung, was es geht jetzt bei React.
Ich steige aus. Aber major, major, huge changes. Massive changes. Okay.
Was ist denn das? Ist das Hugo? Oder was ist das? Das ist Astro? Das ist Quick?
Was? Das ist nicht so. Ah, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten. Okay, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Okay, wir haben noch 5 Minuten Zeit. Wir gucken jetzt in 5 Minuten und 13 Minuten Video. Wobei will ich das überhaupt gucken?
Nee, das will ich gar nicht gucken. Das ist mir vollkommen egal. Nee, das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht.
Das gucken wir doch nicht. Ich hab's mir anders überlegt. Hugo ist written in Go. Ah, okay, aber dann kann es nicht blazingly fast sein.
Können wir noch ein bisschen Ambilight machen? Ja, ich weiß auch schon mit welchem Video. Das hat viele unterschiedliche Farben drin.
Ambilight machen wir. Ambilight. Jetzt geht's nicht, oder? Ambilight. Wo ist es? Ich seh da nix.
Da unten ambient. Ganz kleines bisschen. Excellent. Wahnsinnsambiente. Ja, jetzt ist alles gut.
Noch? Okay, nice. 24 Minuten kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Oh, das ist ein Couch-Disaster. Simplicissimus ist... Also, könnte man fast denken, der hat sich von Levelcap Überschriften inspirieren lassen.
Wie sieht es im Light Mode aus? Das ist eine gute Frage. Das checken wir doch jetzt nochmal schnell. Wie sieht es im Light Mode aus? Also Dark Reader ist aus.
Wie macht man den Light Mode an? Achtung Leute! Achtung! Flashbang! Bam!
Das sieht einfach gar nicht aus im Light Mode. Ach, im Light Mode gibt's das gar nicht. Das ist rein was für Dark Mode.
Wait a minute. Das ist broken.
Das gibt's nicht. Das gibt's nur im Dark Mode.
Das gibt's nur im Dark Mode. Echtes Ambiente gibt es nur im Dark Mode, ja. Wie... Sagt mal, Chet, Chet, wer von euch kümmert sich um den Mod-Channel, äh, um den VOD-Channel?
Ähm, war der nicht gebannt? Habt ihr nicht erzählt, der war gebannt? Warum ist der jetzt wieder da? Ist das ein neuer VOD-Channel?
Best Game Ever, aber sowas von... Gibt das dort eigentlich auch manchmal Kommentare?
Tja, jetzt wär's cool, wenn man mal die Videos nach Meist kommentiert oder so sortieren könnte, aber sowas gibt's ja nicht.
Meist gesehen, zeig mal her. Most popular. Linux Server Hetzener Cloud. Fünf Daumen hoch, boah, Wahnsinn.
Gehold vs. Edgard. Null Daumen hoch. Unraid ausprobiert.
Ist das so beliebt, das hätt ich gar nicht gedacht. Null. Naja. Das Archiv ist wirklich nice geworden.
Ja, da müssen wir wirklich mal Mod-Check für den Serious Max machen. Also im Archiv hat er sich hier selbst, selbst übertroffen.
Das Archiv hat Features, da kann YouTube von dräumen. Erstens ist das schnell und zweitens, passt mal auf.
Das hat einen Transcript. Man kann meine Videos durchsuchen nach dem, was ich gesagt habe. Das ist geil, oder?
Und sogar per Volltext-Suche hier oben drüber. Guck, Keckl. Hallo, hab ich in fast jedem Stream gesagt.
Und wisst ihr, wie er das gemacht hat? Ich sag jetzt mal wir, ich hab da eigentlich wenig mitgemacht, aber ich hab's zumindest bezahlt.
Wir haben uns eine Cloud VR mit Grafikkarte gemietet und haben das dann per Grafikkarte und Machine Learning processed.
Nein, kein Lucin-Index, ein Postgres Volltext-Suche-Index. Das Archiv ist Massive Sixhead, Alter. Das gibt's nix.
Ja, Champ, ich muss jetzt eigentlich auch pennen gehen. Das ist, da reicht sieben Kopf noch nicht mal für, aber mindestens sieben Kopf.
Wie läuft die Arbeitssuche? Du wirst nicht glauben, also da sag ich jetzt noch kurz zu, hab ich eben vorhin auch schon erzählt.
Du wirst nicht glauben, ich hab das Video hochgeladen und hatte quasi instant eine Anfrage vom Ex-Arbeitskollege Max, wir haben einen Job für dich.
Den schicke ich jetzt in meine Lebenslauf- und Skill-Liste und dann machen wir da was.
Die neuen Streams, die werden aktuell noch über die Grafikkarte transcribed.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, warten wir halt mal immer mal einen Monat ab und kaufen uns dann für ein paar Stunden diese VM.
Das ist eine VM mit einer 3090 TI oder einer 3090 oder sowas.
Kost 200 Euro im Monat, ist nicht das billigste.
Ey, das ist nicht mit Kubernetes gehorstet. GPU passt zu und Kubernetes will ich sagen, dass es nicht geht, ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht so das einfachste.
Wir haben einen Swagger-RP-Index, guckt euch das mal an hier, was wir alles haben.
Die haben noch keine 4090 im Angebot, ne.
Aber im Dezember baue ich mir einen neuen Rechner, 4090, fette CPU.
Ich bin noch ein bisschen unschlussig, ob Intel oder AMD. Eigentlich AMD, für meine Use-Cases hat Intel ein bisschen mehr Leistung.
Dafür verbraucht Intel abfuck viel Strom unter Last, die neuen Intel-CPUs.
Und die 4090 frisst ja schon ordentlich.
AMD ist da schlimmer, bist du dir sicher. Ich habe letztens Benchmarks geguckt und Tests gelesen.
Irgendwie, was, 13.000, irgendetwas versus 7.950 und da war Intel vor AMD mit Stromverbrauch.
Bei den Allerneuesten.
Sogar eine ganze Ecke höher als AMD.
Gibt es einen Server-Provider, den du empfehlen kannst? Ja, Hetzner.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat und du kannst probieren, ob du noch 20€ Startguthaben bekommst oder...
Ich vermute, dass es nicht funktioniert, aber du kannst es mal probieren.
Ja, wir gucken uns dann mal die Tage Benchmarks an, aber Hetzner kann ich empfehlen.
Wenn du VMS willst, wenn du VMS willst, wenn du Managed Datenbanken, Managed Kubernetes oder sonstigen Gedöns haben willst, bist du bei Hetzner falsch.
Da musst du einen anderen Cloud-Anbieter suchen, aber wenn du wirklich VMS haben willst, finde ich Hetzner Cloud ist das beste.
Preise sind okay, Traffic ist teils inklusive.
Das Web-Interface ist auch ziemlich gut.
Ansonsten kannst du es automatisieren, mit was du willst, mit Pulumi oder mit Terraform oder mit Ansible gibt es für alles Provider.
Kannst sogar deine Domains dort mit den DNS-Servern betreiben.
Also nicht umziehen zu denen, sondern in den DNS-Servern verwenden.
Kannst du mit den DNS-AP-Let's Encrypten machen und solche Geschichten.
Managed Loadbalancer haben sie, das ist aber das einzige, was es da noch weiter neben VMS gibt.
In der Richtung Managed Loadbalancer.
Da kannst du beispielsweise auch Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat automatisch ausstellen lassen und sowas.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn du weitere Managed-Dachen suchst, brauchst du was anderes.
Was steht da bei Status?
Der hat sogar ein Uptime-Kuma.
Lustig, dass wir am Start haben.
Okay Leute, jetzt gehe ich aber echt ins Bett.
Wir sehen uns, die Tage, macht's gut, bis dann, see you.